I think there has to be consequences I
think women I made a comment of the day
on this post and I got a lot of backlash
about I don't think it's difficult to
not get pregnant yes you're correct yeah
I've never found it difficult don't get
pregnant I've never been pregnant
because I've taken my birth control yes
um but yeah I think that in an Ideal
World birth control wouldn't need to
exist but wishes wouldn't need to exist
I am pro-abortion but
point being we're not in an Ideal World
we're in a side of people that have free
will self-determinations their own
environments they will never conform to
those things it will not stop it
happening people want to have sex let's
try the time let's try a bunch of horny
people in this world and they're not
going to stop [ __ ] because abortion
and and the like is is you know banned
okay I just I I feel like when people
like Thomas Soul always talks about it
like when people face the consequences
of their decisions they make better
decisions yeah generally generally
speaking but as we let's try it
as we can see this is just often not the
not the case though right as we were
talking about people having you know
dozens yeah exactly yeah but there are a
lot of times they're incentivized to do
so yeah like because like Nick Cannon
all those girls are taken care of yeah
yeah so so it's not like a con they
didn't get a consequence they got a
payout yeah yeah people are generally
going to do what they're what they're
incentive device to do you know and I
think one of the big problems we have in
in modern Western Society is that on a
lot of different issues on a lot of
things the incentives are just broken
right bad activities are incentivized
and good positive wholesome things are
often disincentivized or sometimes even
punished
um and I I don't I don't think it's good
I think you know long term that's going
to cause that's going to cause a lot of
chaos and these things are generational
and the more millions of children you
have growing up in certain circumstances
and modeling certain behaviors it's just
going to get exponentially worse
um with each generation so you know I'm
just big I'm big I'm very big on
personal responsibility and
accountability and I think it's much
better to make good decisions
up front rather than you know mess up in
all these very consequential ways and
then now you've Downstream now the line
we know everyone everyone has to clean
up the mess you know it's not just an
individual because we all Impact our
societies that we live in
I actually think men are more like
irresponsible when it comes to
reproduction so I actually think it
should be the other way right more
irresponsible yeah they're more
irresponsible women are more responsible
30 of women that have had abortion no 40
of women that have had abortions have
had two or more come on yeah but they're
more men that have a lot of baby mamas
no they're not yes they are no 40 only
40 of men have even reproduced
historically
so throughout history most men like
getting to reproduce was a privilege
like women aren't most men aren't even
having sex like one out of three men
under 30 are virgins
one out of one out of three men under 30
or either virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year
uh
so that's not true is these stats in
America yeah there's no it's here too
it's in the west every single there's no
because
no it's it's okay it's because
there's a whole there's a whole group of
men you guys just don't see because you
guys are pretty girls and so you're not
gonna notice the guy that's like working
at Tesco involuntary celibacy does not
exist for women
the reason that women like the reason
that women think about are cheating or
think about her trash is because
literally we're all sleeping with the
same one yeah yeah because like women
women the number one way people are
meeting nowadays is social media and and
you know on social media you can be more
honest I'm not social media dating apps
and so you know women only swipe right
between five to twenty percent of the
time even even if we doubled it let's
say let's say it's 40 of the time like
that's still sixty percent of men that
no one like no one wants
um yeah and but I still think the
desired men the ones in this 10
they should they should give them some
responsibility because I agree with you
they keep happening
legally Legally they do though they're
on the hook for child support like the
difference is like men actually have a
consequence where women don't because
whatever bad decision we make we're
always paid out like so if we get
pregnant we can get child support or we
can get married to the guy and take half
in a divorce
in child support only like the rich ones
like the ones literally from Tesco
they're not paying it we're women okay
women women typically don't sleep with
broke men and if they do they're usually
very no no wait let me let me let me let
me let me finish if they do they're
usually very attractive so the incentive
for the girl is to get good genes from
the guy basically man you know what
maybe maybe those are only those
religions had a point
maybe they'd work this stuff out
thousands of years ago and we're like
you know what people should get married
and have sex in that relationship and
have children in that relationship and
that's just clean and it works
just saying you don't think it's better
now
what's better you don't think
relationships are better now
oh my oh my yeah
man there's a lot of you know I I think
as a society with a lot of things
sometimes we're we're way too quick to
assume that an old idea is a bad idea
right there are bad old ideas and
there's lots of bad new ideas as well I
think we started the first how hour and
a half of the conversation with a bad
new idea
um you know but I I think we want to
look towards what worked whether whether
an idea or concept is New or Old you
know I think if something works and has
a clear function and benefit then I
generally think it's it's foolish to
throw it away or jettison it or not not
cons not at least consider it in the
context of potential
ideas and solutions because some of
these problems are age-old for thousands
and thousands of years this conversation
it wasn't happening like this on a
podcast
we're modern today people have always
been horny like people have always had
sex drives like we've always been re you
know we exist because of it literally
um but it's always changed that so
um was it Henry day because you wanted
to marry another woman so he changed the
laws to say that he can get married
again so actually it's always men men
are the problem it's not a woman
their legs closed what do you call a
woman oh come on
okay okay I just went to Carnival to do
interviews yeah you're telling me that
men are the problem when these women are
walking around in thongs in public
now you're not supposed to look sexy I
mean I you could look sexy and keep it
classy like you know there's a I think
there's a difference between like you
know a little leg a little cleavage and
like I don't know a thong
so it's your fault that you had sex with
you because you were wearing a thong uh
I'm saying that women are in control of
sex men are in control of relationships
yeah I both in control of both no no no
control of sex too you can decide you
know what I don't want to have sex I
think Pearl is talking about the
ultimate decision right that ultimately
it's you know
God forbid you know freaking grape
um you know ultimately
the women are The Gatekeepers of six
yeah right
um which is why
if you want to see the up this is why
like gay dudes just you know have way
way way higher numbers of sexual because
females not involved right like it's
just dudes being dudes and they go do
their you know do their things it's very
different
um so yeah women are ultimately the The
Gatekeepers of sex and I think that when
it comes to relationships and commitment
and I think this is the point Pearl is
making men tend to be the ultimate
Gatekeepers of that of how they want
that relationship to proceed if they
want that to be okay cool like this is
exclusive or this is you know a marriage
or what what what whatever it is you
know obviously with a marriage obviously
a woman has to has to say yes to a
proposal
um but yeah I think I think the general
point there is true but I think when it
comes to the responsibility of Sex and
the responsibility of what is Downstream
from sex I put that 50 50. 90 10.
I have concerns about like letting any
sex even if it is my own my own male sex
off the hook I'll give you more a lot a
lot of a lot of bad behavior
um
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible